okay thank you very much uh
yes
this is the last session of this
conference
and i'm a
fifth year graduate student in major
university
and i'm studying about physics and
particularly the research area is
quantum chaos
especially i study this
anisotropic capra problem with
so
i i'm going to tell you about the
study
with mathematical and this is
our laboratory teams
and my professor and my older
teammate and this is me
and the prone to talk uh
firstly i talk about what is anisotropic
kepler problem
and i introduced the scar
phenomena
for the example
of the
correspondence between the quantum and
classical
mechanics
and the next
i pay
attention to
periodic orbits and
i
introduced
the daviest case surface
and the such algorithm are peric orbits
and
the we
i talked i'm going to tell talk about
the proof of uterus conjecture and
russia's conclusion
first
what is nkp
anisotropic two-dimensional akp
hamiltonian is this
this is evaluation of hydrogen atom also
called
uh kepler problem
and
the mu and new is not
is not equal does not equal
the
one
so
this is
a nice traffic
and this um
akp the cultisti
defined only this gamma
and
this scammer
is
shows mass ratio of akp
and the quality of akp depends on only
this one parameter
and
in the akp
with high mass analysis therapy
is there exists uh
some theory and conjecture uh firstly it
exists on
orbit on
for
any given
any given binary code
and it is supposed to be unique this is
good surface conjecture
and this is the most fundamental
periodic orbits
this one
and next
in quantum cares
uh period orbit
a peric orbit is so
a
significant key
and to investigate the
correspondence between quantum mechanics
and classical mechanics
so guterres has son
uh perry obviously and his transformer
and this
equation is the main key
of
his
good retrace formula
next
i introduced
example
of the
correspondence between quantum
and
quantum mechanics and crash current
mechanics
it is quite phenomenal
firstly i
think in
this new new coordinates
and
this is the result
energy level this is
energy levels
a in akp as gamma equals 0.2
and this is the
probability
a
2454 and 5 6 7 8 and the
probability shape in akp
has many variety
but
especially this
uh
this probability at
257
uh
trace
the crash card fundamental paragraph
orbit
the shape
so it is this is this car
this is a skirt
and
i wanna
look
is
the scar phenomena
more
quantified so i quantified
i do the quantification of scar strength
they use
with the use of this funct shim khan's
simi function and this strength function
so
this is the result and
sketch strength function
has some peak
this one and this one this one and as
this peak portion
uh
the
uh probability and this
representation in mu premium space
uh
skull is occurred
at this
peak position
and and this is also
all
understanded
by
apparently orbit theory and this is
this is it and this is the prediction
from the perigee orbit theory
and this peak position
and this and this
shows
uh
scar pollution
but this and this
actually
it shows
anti-skull pollution
it is
very interesting phenomena but i don't
know
oh
more more men more
and
we introduce
3d presentation in purely output orbit
uh this is the
fundamental paradigm of it
in
in this
new new pmu space and
other period of it is this
and next
uh i pay attention the period of it
itself
firstly
uh i introduce
the debut staircase surface
in this
table in this tumor
i use this x logix larger use paste
and
i
guess
this bunker surface section code
and this progress surface
section is
picked at y equals zero
and we change
i change this code to
a binary code and
i construct
this binary number
for
each paragraph of it
each orbit sorry
so this is the result is this and
uh
this
at
you you go
arbitrary you
you value
for example
or you go at zu
at equal zero
this curve
this car
is
shows
they will still case
and
it is uh
i mean
it's it's
by
the meaning of fractality
and so we call this surface
the
wck surface
and
this is the essence of
akp e
obvious akp obvious is a this is ss
so
we
we
sold
we can
search
the initial point of peric orbit
from this
object
this is the
that such algorithm
such arguments the first step is the
search of level contour at
target periodic orbit
and
eber is target orbit binary code and
the target binary code number is
constructed by this error
so
if i select
some arbitrary
binary code
and
we can guess this contour
and the concept so
all is
uh consequent minimization along this
level control uh in in general in
general uh
uh
as
long
along the
arbitrary direction
of
chi square values
is
so jaggy the curve is jaggy for example
or x zero equal one this
this yellow arrow
along this
arrow
this
curve
uh
the
casual cup is this
it's so jaggy and it is too difficult to
search
is the initial point of
akp or perigorbit but
along the
contour curve
the classical value is this and
it is so simple
convex curve and with
only one bottom
and it is that is this is the initial
point of wanted perfect orbit
and
as a result we can
searched
a
period orbit and the number of the
orbit we searched
is
19284
and this is some example
uh
this is no symmetry type and this is
extra from
mission symmetry type
and this is y symmetry time
and
this is both symmetry time
type i'm sorry
and
next
we
investigate
structure of gss
and
to use investigate the
structure of the dss
the key is
this
one-time map
this red region
and brew and this some car is
showing
this one
red red region
uh represent now is plus
and next is plus
and blue region is
uh now is plus
about next region is minus
and so this one is zero equal plus a y
equal minus and p
pink
region is uh
now is minus and next is brush
ingredients minus and minus
so
for example
if i select this position
the orbit arrived
at
this point
from here
to here
so
with the use of this
one-time map
we can
explain
the monotonicity of the debut straight
case
surface and the structure itself
this is the basic concept of
iteration so
mathematical index mathematical
induction and firstly
we prepared
this
one-time map
and
we act this
one-time map
to this
user
x0 user plane
so we can get the next step
next bonus surface
section play
so-called x1 u1 plane and next
we ask
one time up to
this
xy1 play
then
we can guess the extrude to play and
more and more more more
we can get
the
information of arbitrary
progress office obsession
and
one-time map explains
the
region spreading and montreal city
first tree
a
will copy and paste
the boundary
of
red and
between red and blue
this this curves
copy and paste to
this x11 plane
so this
region
the next of this region is plus and
the next of this region
is minus
so
this region
is the length of this region is plus of
a plus and the next of this region
next is minus
so
i
so
i understand this
way
by this way
x2 youtube the sign of
x2u2 plane
and
if i
on time
f inverse
this
curve
the
result is this one
and this region the next region is plus
and this
minus
so
oh very topologically
this is plus and this is minus
as
x to you to play
so
we can
understand
the
monotonous city and
region spreading
is
uh
at
this
direction
and actual result is this
first three this is the
first
quadrant
representing only this cluster quadrants
representation
and
firstly he
of course
plus only but
next is
we we can
two steps we can make two steps and more
and
more and more more more more more
as a result we can guess
dss
by mathematical indexing
so
by about
the
the talks
we can
improve the good spirit conjecture
firstly
each period of it exists on each steps
each type of wstrk surface respectively
a
and two
all kind of very binary codes exist in
the debugging state case surface
so
there exists one a one two one
correspondence between uh binary code
and the
uh period of it
for all kind of binary causes
so we can improve the
conjecture by mathematical induction
rust conclusion
firstly
period orbit is significant key to
investigate the quantum classical
correspondence
for example phenomenon
and next
the
complete list
of the large hand along 10 pairing
orbits are obtained
if if you
want to
all pair your orbit other periodic
orbits so please access
this account
so
this is
this is
all this is
perfect orbits
or old yes
and suddenly we can
successfully prove exaggerated
conjecture
by mathematical induction
and
a part of the results
have been given
by through the mathematical stuff in
computing power
for example flexibility integration with
any precision
visualization and more and more and his
or uh
which is correct please tell me
excuse me
which which excuse me
which is correct mathematical is
female or male
you do
uh
okay uh
he his
or her heart pearl is so useful in our
study
and
uh
i appreciate it so much thank you very
much that's all